all right something super interesting is
starting to happen within the Republican
party there is a campaign that has
started a silent campaign or let's not
silent a quiet campaign to be Donald
Trump's running mate in 2024. now Donald
Trump hasn't even announced many of
Donald Trump's endorsees did terribly in
the midterms and lost there are
increasingly Republicans who say Donald
Trump shouldn't even run and as we
recently saw the betting markets now
feel that it is more likely that Ron
DeSantis is the 2024 Republican nominee
than it is Trump but there are Trump
sycophants the Trump suck UPS the Trump
brown-nosers who are desperate to be
Donald Trump's running mate one such
individual is radical republican
congresswoman Marjorie Taylor green
Marjorie Taylor green has been floated
as a possibility for Donald Trump's
running mate in 2024 we know that Donald
Trump after his falling out with Mike
Pence will not be choosing Pence to run
with him in 24 if indeed he chooses to
be a candidate and there have also been
Rumblings of is it possible that Ron
DeSantis would run or be Trump's VP I
don't think that's likely is it possible
that Kerry Lake if she becomes Governor
would then try to become Trump's VP
Marjorie Taylor green doesn't like it
and Marjorie Taylor green is now framing
this as DeSantis and Lake
shouldn't abandon their states abandon
their states this is very interesting
Marge is angling to be Trump's VP
earlier we also talked and we said if
anyone steps into the uh political ring
and tries to challenge president Trump
as far as being the Republican nominee
for 2024 we feel like his political
suicide this is his
party this is his race to run do you
want to share your thoughts on that
yesterday's results call that assessment
into question by the way absolutely I
think
I think he's the one that we elected in
2016 we re-elected him in 2020 and we
will elect him in 2024. what we need in
this country Brian is we need strong
Republican Governors like Ron DeSantis
we need strong Republican Governors we
didn't Kerry Lake to win in Arizona we
need strong Republican Governors to
fight stay in for eight years and save
their states not to abandon their states
and try to run for president or any
other big position so I wonder why she
feels that way this is for everyone
anyone that's considering running uh for
president in 2024 against President
Trump please support president Trump
because we need him back in the White
House yeah and we need him to be the
nominee so that he picks me to be his
running mate only a trump supporter
would view other candidates engaging in
the Democratic process as an act of
betrayal think about how backwards that
is think about it
Marjorie Taylor green is saying
if you don't simply lay down
and let Trump have the nomination if he
wants it it's in some way a betrayal if
you're a governor and you say I'm gonna
go run for president you're abandoning
your state all of this stuff is
completely self-serving and by the way
Marjorie Taylor green wants to be VP
despite the fact that she has done
absolutely nothing for her constituents
as a representative for the state of
Georgia they need Trump confirmed as the
de facto candidate quickly because they
want to put political pressure on the
investigations that are taking place to
try to end them they have a lot of
different reasons why they want Trump to
very quickly announce and have everyone
else get out of the way if indeed Trump
follows through with announcing next
Tuesday that's part of the motivation
they want everybody to get out of the
way they want to use it to try to
suppress investigations but also they
want to move on to this PR campaign for
Who Will trump choose as his running
mate Marjorie Taylor green wants to be
that person